i'm kevin sentiment from GQ magazine out
here in northern california to talk
about the smart fortwo which comes out
in the united states in January 2008 one
of the first things you notice when you
actually see one of these things is how
tall they actually are it's more
spacious than you would imagine one of
the biggest concerns with the car of
this size is is it safe
and the key to the safety of the smart
fortwo is this thing they call the
tritium cell which is a lot like a
safety cage of a NASCAR this is it's
super stiff steel in addition to that on
the inside you've got two front airbags
and these two side airbags
oh I'll pop this off for you all these
body panels Amana plastic which makes it
pretty much that proof when you get a
scratch you're not gonna see like a
white line because the plastic is
actually poured with the color so it's
it's red all the way through so in the
front here you have your fluids and the
engine is actually in the rear it's
three cylinders 70 horsepower it's
enough to get this thing going cuz it's
so light but you're not gonna be winning
any drag races so even though the smart
car is under 9 feet long it has this
really wide door so getting in and out
is super easy and when you're inside the
first thing you notice is how spacious
it is plenty of legroom plenty of
shoulder room so you're not gonna be you
know rubbing arms with the dude next
year there's plenty of headroom well the
tops down so you're just gonna have to
take my word for it what are the cool
things about the Cabriolet version when
you have the top down you can pop off
this part of the car and give it a
cleaner look even stow it away back here
so it's not bouncing around from the
backseat
I'm sure what you really want to know is
how this thing drives so let's take a
ride
we're in on skyline Boulevard here
outside of the let's go the one thing I
was really surprised with is how well
this handles terms
it's pretty easy to like dart in and out
of profit because it's such a short car
inside there it's everything it's its
size like like the normal boss when I
first saw the car you're like no way you
can get this thing up to 70 right now
I'm going about 75 miles per hour I've
gotten it up 80 85 miles per hour it's
an automatic departments also remain a
moment driving this thing it's almost
like
in town
one of the big selling points about a
smart car other than in size is the
mileage against the smart fortwo is
actually one of the most fuel-efficient
cars on the road and it actually has
half the carbon footprint of a Toyota
Prius which is pretty surprising
considering it's a gas car the smart car
looks like it's just revealed very much
at home in urban environments where
you're in stop-and-go traffic where
you're trying to look for a parking
space but I was surprised when I got on
the highway how how comfortable let's do
that when you're driving this thing
people will just come right up to you
there if they're like if do is he
actually like awesome car that guy gave
me more of like the surfer
I think it was around I'm not sure I was
only mopped once by a group of teenagers
but other than that people were pretty
excited to see this market